hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the 2015 macbook the new macbook
review uh this laptop's been out for a
little while now and people have made
their choice if they want to buy it or
not but i still wanted to give my
thoughts and my impressions of it since
i've been using it for a bit and just
let you know what i think of it as it
exists now so right off the bat the
number one reason that this machine
exists and the biggest advantage it has
over any of its competitors
is this thinness and lightness it's the
most portable laptop i've ever used by a
long way it measures in at just 35
millimeters at its thinnest point and
135 millimeters at its thickest point
and it weighs in at just 2.03 pounds
which is about as much as two ipad airs
the two main sacrifices apple had to
make to get this thin are the keyboard
and the trackpad which are really your
main ways of interfacing with the laptop
the trackpad which initially seems like
a workaround just to fit into the
thinner body
it turns out to actually be one of the
laptop's best features so instead of the
normal physical diving board mechanism
that works for most laptops the macbook
instead has a solid piece of glass that
doesn't move then it simulates the
sensation of clicks with a vibration
motor and it's very convincing so it
feels like you're clicking a normal
quality trackpad even though it's not
normal as a bonus you also get this
click sensation basically everywhere on
the glass so not just the middle like
normal laptops and you get a different
functionality for different levels of
pressure which is where the name force
touch comes in so force touch acts as a
sort of a more info button letting you
like scrub through media or get
definitions of words that you force
touch in safari and stuff like that i
didn't use force touch stuff all that
much but overall i definitely like the
track pad on this laptop the keyboard on
the other hand is definitely something i
don't like in this super thin laptop
apple switched from normal chiclet style
keys which are on like every apple
keyboard for the past few years to these
butterfly switches which are to make
them thinner but that also means there's
almost zero travel zero clickiness it's
a very mushy unresponsive keyboard and
i'll be honest after a few weeks i
actually did get used to typing on this
keyboard and i stopped messing up and
double pressing letters so many times
but that doesn't mean i enjoyed it but
at least it's possible to get used to it
but the other thing is it's also not a
standard keyboard layout as you can see
by the arrow key is all crunched
together literally the one upside of
this keyboard is that it's backlit and
doesn't look terrible but hey all in the
name of thin and light also it was
apparently a bit too thin for a normal
sized webcam because we got this 480p
webcam
in the new macbook
it doesn't look terrible actually not
that looks awful anyway aside from the
keyboard and the trackpad this is a
really nice well-built quality notebook
as it should be for the price the
display in particular is awesome it is a
crispy retina display and has a
resolution of 2304 by 1440 which
probably seems a little bit weird at a
16 by 10 aspect ratio but that just
means it's able to switch between a
couple of scaled resolutions that affect
the size of things on the screen and it
can be a pretty bright display for
normal viewing or video viewing or
gaming but it also gets pretty dim for
dark environments too another thing
that's awesome right below the display
is this speaker
just
holy
it's really good like best speakers i've
ever heard on a laptop good i don't know
how they did that but this thing sounds
50 times its size it's amazing and yeah
the rest of the laptop is just you know
metal with the classic apple modern
laptop aesthetic so the baseline for
this machine which i got here in space
gray is 300 bucks and it's rocking a 1.1
gigahertz intel core m
8 gigs of ram 256 gigs of storage and
intel's integrated graphics so clearly
not a powerhouse at all and the computer
itself like inside this body is actually
about the size of an iphone and it's
lodged right up near the speaker the
rest is just battery just filled with
battery every bit of space it's fanless
so it's dead silent no vents at all
might get a little bit warmer but it's
just computer and battery
apple claims nine hours of battery life
i found i got more like six of course
i'm using chrome not safari so that's
probably a big enough hit right there
and if you try to do anything much
heavier than web browsing you'll run up
against a wall pretty quickly definitely
want to be plugged in for that so it's
so thin and light that i actually find
myself using this in fact more often
lately in places where i would usually
have used my tablet so it fits in the
same compartments as my nexus 9 and my
ipad it's only a little bit bigger than
them but it's just as lightweight
essentially and it's got a way better
display has a keyboard it's got way more
functionality built in so
it may seem a little bit weird to think
of it this way but this has been an
awesome tablet replacement so if you've
heard of this laptop before or now then
surely you've heard about its infamous
one port it's single port on the side
uh
hope you like dongles in the hand but
hey at least it is usb type-c so usb-c
is one of the most versatile at least
one port solutions you could possibly
have i sort of like to have had two or
three maybe one on each side or
something like that but for now uh it's
not that difficult to adapt to and you
still do have to adapt to it but there
are some adapters obviously in dongles
apple makes some like 80 dongles it
would kind of suck if you lost one of
those but there's also some cheaper
third-party ones but anytime you want to
plug in any accessory beyond just power
or something like a mouse you're going
to have to get an adapter so i did get a
bluetooth mouse so i don't have to use a
dongle for that
but anytime i want to do something past
charging like plug it into a printer or
a monitor or something like that or just
reading an sd card you need that dongle
the usbc port also allows you to charge
up with a portable battery pack if
you're in a pinch but that is pretty
slow so charging with the included usbc
charger takes about two hours and the
only downside is there is no charging
led light like you'd have on a magsafe
charger but really the fact of the
matter is i found myself using this
machine a lot like i was using a tablet
or at least i was using in a lot of the
same situations as a tablet so i didn't
really compare it in my mind to other
laptops even though it's 300 bucks and
even though it's shaped like a laptop
i still compared it to a tablet so the
fact that it only had one port didn't
really bother me i didn't use it in many
situations where i needed more than one
port
and the fact that it has a mushy
keyboard didn't really bother me because
basically every solution adding a
keyboard to a tablet has the same
problem uh battery life would have been
better on a tablet actually than this
but not to make excuses for the thing
but it makes an awesome tablet
replacement that being said if you plan
on using this all the time as a main
laptop you might want to consider
spending your 1300 bucks in a more power
hungry or power efficient place like you
can get a macbook air right now or
plenty of other fan and light laptops
that aren't quite as beautiful and
elegant as this one but will get you
more bang for the buck in that
department but as far as the things that
i use this for this actually turned out
to work really well so i'm not afraid to
say it i really like the new macbook in
a lot of ways it reminds me of a super
premium tablet experience it's silent
it's fast it's got an awesome display
the only thing that's stopping it from
being like my main laptop is the fact
that i do do more high intensive things
on my laptop that require more
performance like video editing photo
editing audio editing those are the
types of things that might require the
word pro at the end of the name but if
even if you're just looking at something
like this and you have 1300 bucks to
spend you could still just get a macbook
air so this is a beautiful awesome
machine but you probably shouldn't buy
it
and that being said the second
generation of this this is a first gen
product is undoubtedly going to be a lot
better and a much better buy now if
you've made it this far and you're still
thinking that this is a laptop for you
at least keep this one thing in mind
it's not upgradable in any way you can't
really get into this machine and upgrade
anything so when you do get it
upgrade the ram upgrade the storage make
sure you have enough to last you as long
as you plan on using this thing but
that's basically it uh it's one of my
favorite laptops that again you probably
shouldn't get same thing i kind of said
about the chromebook pixel
either way thank you for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace